Well,
the most important issue is the one we
just talked about because we're so
mishandling and at this point in time
and that is what is America's proper
role in the world.
The second big issue I think is that
this society is not improving.
One of the things that we've lost
somehow in the United States,
which the puritans brought to us in the
beginning,
was the notion that individual human
beings and societies where the largest
mall should always be trying to improve
themselves.
They should be trying to learn more.
They should be trying to improve their
character,
their service.
There are all kinds of.
We've kind of lost that notion so that
self improvement has become a joke or it
means something like losing some weight
and we have as an we focused instead on
happiness and pleasure and enjoying life
and I think that's a very serious
problem for it.
We ought to talk about that and now
there are issues.
There was the healthcare financing
problem that we have in the United
States.
There is,
there's going to be an economic problem
that we have is coming up.
There are those kinds of issues,
but the really big ones are the ones
that are,
what are we about?
What are we about in the world and what
are we about at home?